SPEAKER: Wolff is here
to talk about basically
two of my favorite things
combined together into one
presentation, and that
is physics engines
and cool physics demos
and live coding, which
is kind of crazy to
combine together,
but that's what he's doing.
WOLFF DOBSON: I am that crazy.
SPEAKER: He is crazy,
WOLFF DOBSON: Can you
hear me, everyone?
SPEAKER: Use the mic.
We've got a live stream.
Oh, you've got it.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm famous
on the internet already.
SPEAKER: All right, then.
WOLFF DOBSON: OK, so
let me start presenting.
I'm Wolff Dobson, I'm a
developer programs engineer,
and I'm going to be talking
to you about LiquidFun, which
is our open source physics
engine that we released
in December and, as of
today, is at version 1.0.
[AUDIENCE CHEERS]
WOLFF DOBSON: Thank you.
Yay!
All right.
So, just to give you
a little preview,
I'm going to talk
about physics engines,
I'm going to do some
demos, I'm going
to actually code in front
of you a little bit.
So if you want to watch a
Google engineer screw-up,
this is your moment.
And I'm going to talk about some
inspiration of what you could
be doing with a physics
engine like this.
So how many of you
guys are engineers?
Anyone?
How many of you
guys are artists?
All right.
So most of you probably at GDC
know what a physics engine is.
It's a system for generating
procedural animations.
In this case,
physical processes.
The one we're
talking about today
is steppable, that means that we
move time a little bit forward,
a little bit forward,
and if things overlap, we deal
with that physical process
in some way that
looks believable.
And we also try to do it in
real time, although you could
I guess use this
offline as well.
A physics engine does not
include rendering code,
although in fact, we do include
rendering code in our test bed,
but we would expect you
guys to use your cool art
and engineering
skills to render all
this stuff in an awesome way.
LiquidFun is based around Box2D.
You've probably seen
this demo, and I'm
going to be bouncing back
and forth between demos quite
a bit.
So, you've all seen this kind
of Box2D sort of looking thing,
right.
It's like a slider crank.
It's got like a box
and another box,
and they're hitting
each other, and there's
like a couple of joints,
and they're cranking around,
and that's Box2D.
And Box2D is really awesome,
but what LiquidFun adds to Box2D
is lots and lots and
lots of particles.
So, whooo!
And this is a live simulation,
so I can throw these particles
around, they can do cool stuff.
These particles can
interact with rigid bodies,
so we can have them all thrown
around and look pretty awesome.
We can do color mixing.
So here we are going to
take this stirrer here,
and we're going to stir this
up, and we're going to get sort
of a uniform grey.
And we can do a
lot of other stuff.
We also do buoyancy.
So the squares are not very
dense, the circle is dense,
and then those two little
arrows there at the bottom
don't displace enough
particles to be floated.
We got a lot of other
stuff, and I could go on
for a long time about this,
but that's the idea, particles.
Particles are awesome, and
they can make your game better.
So heading back to this, doink.
So essentially, Box2D, an
existing thing, LiquidFun
is more on top of
Box2D that gives you
all these awesome particles.
It's cross-platform.
It's written in C++, which
means you can do it on Android.
Yay?
Also Linux, OS X,
Windows, iOS, whatever
you bring to the table.
And we're working
on some more stuff.
We're working on Coco2D-x
integration, which
means you also get Android
and iOS and OS X and Win32,
and like BlackBerry and
all kinds of great stuff.
Daniel Murphy, of JBox2D
fame, has ported this all
over two Java.
So in fact, if you go
to jbox2d.org right now,
it'll just say, Box2D, well,
actually, LiquidFun in Java.
So, we got all these
particles, how do they work?
So a Box2D Rigid Body is an
arbitrary size and an arbitrary
shape, and it's got rotation.
And a particle is basically
the opposite of that.
It's uniform, it's always the
same shape, it's a circle,
it's uniform size, and it
has no rotation at all.
Which means, if you
were rendering them,
they'd all be pointing
the same direction,
even as they moved around.
They're also packed into memory
in a particularly efficient way
that makes them
very fast to render.
So if you've got to render
a whole lot of stuff,
you got to plan ahead for that.
Particles have color,
size, position, velocity,
all of the regular
physical stuff.
They also contain
strength, which
is how much they want to
be next to each other,
and we'll show you how
that works in a second.
Creating a particle.
How many of you guys have
ever done any Box2D work?
Anyone?
Yeah, you got some
guys out there.
This is going to
look really familiar.
ParticleDef is like a stamp.
So you say, I want to make
water particles, and this one I
want to be at position i, zero.
And then you call
CreateParticle,
and it stamps one out for you.
And if you want to make another
one, you call CreateParticle,
and you set a
different position.
You keep going.
That's going to get the
number of particles,
I just showed you
in the dam break.
That's going to take
a really long time,
so we give you particle groups.
Particle groups create and
destroy lots of particles
at the same time.
It also adds
properties all at once.
So you could have a shape that's
a big square and its spinning,
so it's got rotational
velocity and angle,
and then you can also
set the strength,
so you can have them all
work together as a group.
Again, we'll get to that.
Oooh-- foreshadowing,
OK, so particle behaviors.
I just showed you
water particles,
but we also have powder,
we have viscous particles,
which are ones that like
to stick to each other.
Powder particles don't like to
stick to anything, so if you're
going to act like smoke.
Spring particles.
Imagine all your particles
are connected by springs.
Elastic particles.
All your particles are
connected by-- well actually,
it's a little more
complicated than that,
it's how much they want
to retain their shape.
Wall particles, they
don't move at all.
That sounds kind of lame,
but it's actually really cool
and I'll show you how.
And today, LiquidFun
1.0, barrier particles.
Barrier particles are like, you
spray Scotchgard or something
on the particles, like
nothing can interpenetrate
a group of barrier particles.
Static pressure particles.
This is kind of, if you have
a whole bunch of particles
together and you spun
them all at once,
if you don't get them exactly
spaced apart just right,
they're going to sit there
and bounce a little bit
until it comes to rest.
Static pressure particles
take care of that for you.
Particle lifetimes, so if
you're making fountains,
that's going to be
kind of awesome.
Multiple particle systems.
So, you can have a
single particle system
with all these particles
interacting with each other.
You can also have several
layers of particle systems.
So if you have a volcano
way in the background that's
doing its thing, you don't need
those particles to interact
with anything else, so you can
put that in a separate particle
system.
And it's better.
You should check out
our release notes.
I could get really nerdy
with you, but trust me,
it's way better.
So here's the scary part.
This is when I'm going
to code a little bit.
I'm going to be using
XCode plus Cocos2D iPhone
and running it on
iOS, and as a Googler,
that means I have
a great commitment
to cross-compatibility.
But we have this all running for
Android and C++, and in fact,
we're just doing it all on
C++, and they're going to be
the same in either language.
So, let's start with a
standard Box2D implementation.
So I go over to XCode here.
I hide you because I don't
need you anymore for right now.
And here we go.
Thank goodness, my
build succeeded.
OK.
So this is your
standard Box2D going on.
When I click, I drop a
box, and they kind of
ricochet off each other.
So let's add something to this.
Let's add a particle group.
Now I'm cheating a little
bit because I actually
practiced this beforehand,
so I coded it up.
So when you create a
particle group, whoosh!
You get a lot of water.
That's kind of cool.
And if we go back to my
slides for a second, what
we did there is we
created a particle system.
Creating a particle
system is like,
hey world, make me
a particle system.
And you set some
default properties
on the particles, so radius,
density, things like that.
And then I created
a particle group,
which means I take a
standard Box2D polygon shape,
I set it as a box in the middle.
And then I want to
make water particles,
I want to set all the
particles in this group
to be the same colors, and then
I call CreateParticle groups.
So we have these groups.
And I keep talking
about strength,
and this is where I make
good on my foreshadowing.
You can also make jellies
out of these things.
And what you do then
is you say, instead
of making water particles, I
want to make elastic particles.
And then I add a group flag to
it, so I want them to be solid.
Which means, I don't
want other particles
interpenetrating my group.
I'll tolerate it
for a little bit,
but eventually I'm
going to reject it.
So let's take a look.
Let's get rid of
this-- oh no, let's
leave that on there, a
little water is kind of fun.
But let's, instead
of when I click,
I'm going to add a jelly.
So here you go, we're back.
And I click, and, oh yeah.
It's all gooey and weird.
And you can set the
strength, how much you
want all these guys
to be touching--
how much they want
to be together.
You can see if I-- I
actually accidentally
made gameplay in here.
One thing that turns
out to be really fun
is trying to stack these as
high as possible without-- see,
it fell over.
Also, because they're
solid particle groups,
they don't want
to interpenetrate.
So if I kind of put them
on top of each other,
they'll eventually
separate themselves.
So they don't want
to be part of this.
And you can see
gravity and stuff
is acting on all this elastic
that is keeping them together.
So that's kind of cool.
And that's like a
game, right there,
is like stacking
these gooey things.
And again, you can stiffen them
up or make them totally blobby,
but I thought that
was really cool.
Let's stop doing that though,
because it's too silly.
Instead, we're going to throw
down a particle emitter.
So-- go back to my slides.
When you're making
a particle emitter,
it's a little bit more code.
And in fact, we give you a
sample one in our sample code.
But basically every
step, you count out
how much time has passed,
and you figure out
how many particles per
second that you want to emit
and then just stamp out that
many using CreateParticle.
And in this case, because we
want it to feel like a faucet,
we give it a starting velocity.
Because when you
turn on your faucet,
the water doesn't just
suddenly exist and then
sort of fall into your sink.
It's being pushed by a
whole bunch of stuff.
So we're going to give
it a starting velocity.
So if we head back
to XCode here,
I'm going to turn on
my particle emitter.
And when I run it, we get
particles flowing out here.
And these particles
will kind of push
around these boxes,
which is kind of cool.
And you can see here I actually
have different particle groups.
I have the blue particle group
and the white particle group,
and they're mixing.
And they're perfectly
happy because they're not
trying to be solid.
But the problem here
is this isn't much fun.
I mean, I can kind of
stack and have stuff--
So let's go down to where we
create a particle emitter,
and instead of having the
water start flowing downwards,
let's just fire it off
to the right really fast.
So when we do that, now
you get this stream.
And since they are being
distributed randomly
across a horizontal
line, it ends up just
being a jet going this way.
And so if I throw
particles in-- well,
that's not really
strong enough is it.
Ah, what we need is
heavier particles.
So we can find the
particle system
and say "set particle
density" and oh look,
I happen to have written
this and commented it out.
Let's set it to something big.
And we can also set the
default size of the particles
up a little bit.
I'm going to make them bigger.
They're not going to render
any bigger because we haven't
changed the renderer,
but I'm going
to make them sort
of mentally bigger.
So here we go.
We do this.
We've got that same thing.
You can see the particles are
spaced out a little bit more,
and then when I drop one
of these things in, ah,
here we go.
Now we have a game.
Now we're like, how many
of these can-- shoot,
I was really good at this
when I was practicing.
I could get three of them
stacked up over here.
There's one-- two-- oh-- I don't
think it's going to work-- yay!
OK.
Again--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, thank you.
But in all seriousness,
here we have another kind
of game play in
here, just by making
these jets of all these
particles running around.
So let's-- All right,
let me stop coding
because it's getting too silly.
Let's head back to the slides.
And what you saw here was
me creating a particle
group and a particle system,
creating elastic particles,
and creating a particle emitter.
We have sample code
for all this stuff.
Check it out on our website.
Let's talk about what
you can do with this.
Now, when I was thinking
about all the different ways,
and my teammates were helping
me think of crazy ways
to use a particle
system, we were
thinking about different
modalities, different ways
you can group
thinking about this.
So obviously what we just
did there was moving things
with jets, so you could imagine
"Flappy Bird" being sprayed
up and down instead of
just flapping up and down,
and that would be a different
thing, kind of weird.
Mini-golf being played
with fire hoses instead
of regular mini-golf, could
be scary, could also be fun.
You could stir a fluid
to move an object around.
So you could have a bath
tub full of rubber ducks,
trying to get the
rubber ducks to go
someplace, that's something.
And you could also
use the particles
to push things, kind
of like a rocket,
and I just happen to
have a demo about that.
So if we head back to this
guy, here's one of the demos
that we made during one of
our internal hackathons.
Where's Sparky?
There's Sparky.
So in Sparky, each time
these rigid bodies,
which are this big
circles, touch each other,
it creates a
particle group that's
packed really tightly
together and then has
velocity all facing outwards.
So as a result, you
get this explosion.
Then we give it trippy colors
so you can sit and stare
at it while your
screen saver is on.
But this is kind of cool.
You can imagine having
rockets being propelled
by creating particles that
are pushing against it
and driving it
upwards like that,
and it would give a really
interesting locomotion.
Let's go back slides.
We can also do water
as a destructor.
So putting out fires would
be an obvious sort of thing.
You can imagine sitting
there like having
to tap on your screen to try to
make the water get high enough
to put out a fire
on different floors.
You could have multiple
particle systems
so the fire is on
one particle system,
the water is on another.
The tidal wave that
ate San Francisco.
You can attach a
bunch of rigid bodies
by joints the break
easily and then hit
them really hard with a bunch
of high-density particles,
and I guarantee they'll get
knocked all over the place.
Speaking of knocking
particles all over the place,
you could say, just have a
little stick figure here,
and then you could blast
him off into space,
and that would be
kind of awesome too.
Oh-- poor guy.
Anyway, going back.
You could also imagine
fluid being sorted.
Now there's, "Where's
my Water?" is a game
in which you dig to
sort of sort and control
where you want the water to go.
The demo that I made
was drawing things
that allow you to control
where water is going.
And again, there's
a game in here.
You could have red
emitters and blue emitters,
and you're trying to
decide where they're going,
or something, get pumps pushing
them different directions.
No matter what, I think
there's something there.
Think about fracking.
Fracking is basically
a particle system.
Because when you're fracking,
you have basically a big matrix
with lots of little
holes in it, and you've
got a bunch of
stuff that's fluid
that you want to get
out of it, and you're
pumping some other
waste product in there
to shove that into some
straw that you're sucking out
of that.
And we actually made
a little fracker game,
and we just barely explored
it, and it was totally fun.
Going onwards.
Think of water as a medium.
So rather than controlling the
water or pouring the water,
water is just the thing
that you're traversing.
So buoyancy games.
Obviously boats, boats are
in water, that could work.
I think surfing is probably
a little bit more interesting
because there you're
interacting with sort
of the angle, the wave, and
the pressure and everything.
Fluids as terrains, if
you have cars and mud,
and I just love this picture
because that dude totally
parked in front of the horse,
but the thing about that is it
also brings up legged animals.
So if you have some
sort of legged animal
that was trying to
stumble through-- wait,
I actually wrote that.
So we go back here, Theo
Jansen's walker right here.
This is a very
famous Box2D demo.
And all I did was add
a particle emitter
that emitted snow, so sort
of light, fluffy particles
and already a couple of kinds
of game play come out of this.
One is that he can carry
it around on his head,
as you can see.
And another thing
is that he actually
acts as a little snow plow.
And I mean, I'm from California,
so I don't really get snow,
but I assume this
is how they move
snow, giant legged beasts
that wander around like this.
That's what I'm told.
Anyway, I think that's a really
interesting-- there's already
gameplay kind of
spilling out of this
as I was just goofing around.
Lastly, bottom line is this.
If you're using
Box2D-- how many of you
guys are using
Box2D in your game?
Anybody?
Yeah.
All right.
You're basically
LiquidFun ready.
To do the Cocos2D
thing that we did,
we basically just went
into the Box2D folder,
deleted the old one, and
pasted the new one on top.
And it's the same folders
and the same headers,
it's just an extra
directory called particles
that implements all
this particle stuff.
An hour is maybe a little
bit of an exaggeration
because you still
have to do a renderer.
We give you a sample
renderer, but I
think you're going to
want to make a better one,
and, you know, think
about that Android.
So where do I get it?
You can get it from
our GitHub page.
If you want the Java
version, go to jbox2d.org.
And if you want anything else,
or if you have questions,
you can email me, and
I will respond to them.
We also have a Google group
where you can ask questions.
If you want technical questions,
that's probably faster
because I do sleep
from time to time.
And plus, our eng team
reads it, and they're
super happy to answer
your questions.
So one more demo.
Very last thing I'm
going to show you.
All the demos I've shown
you up to this point
were either in the test bed,
or they're in the Cocos thing
where I was rendering all the
particles as little squares.
That's not as good as
it's going to look.
So instead, I'm going to
show you the eye candy demo,
and this is actually an early
version of the eye candy demo.
The new one is even better.
But what you've got
here is beautifully
rendered particles,
same physics.
Here there's even some
memory in the image,
it's a multipass renderer,
so you can actually
see smearing out over time.
You can also do transparency.
That looks kind of awesome,
at least I think it's awesome.
So there you go.
That's LiquidFun, and we
want you guys to use it.
Drop us a line if you have it.
It's open source.
Try it today.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]